just approaching in the Grand Canal
shops inside the Venetian will be
hosting many celebratory events so
joining us now is z Jay Tong a China
specialist at the Grand Canal shops and
Tori Ishida the entertainment and
special events manager with the Grand
Canal shots welcome to the show thank
you CJ I'm gonna start with you give us
a little brief history of the Lunar New
Year well the Lunar New Year really
started from a ancient Chinese myth
where a animal called a beast or monster
called nien according to the myth this
nien the monster lives out of a mountain
a much of the year it is there however
on the New Year's Eve it will come out
and Destroy people's lives and eat
children and livestocks because we do a
lot of bad things but Chinese eventually
realized that the monster nien is afraid
of red color and is afraid of loud sound
okay so that's why now that you see a
lot of celebrations that we have red
colors yes put it on the door on the
wall and the window and people wearing
red so that first of all it's it's very
cheerful and second of far is the word
of evil spirits and of course Chinese
invented firecrackers so we see a lot of
fire that's why during the Chinese New
Year as well this is amazing very
educational now 2023 is the year of the
rabbit why is it the year of the rabbit
there are 12 animals so uh according to
Chinese zodiac so this we're still in
the year of the tiger next year is the
year of the rabbit and after that will
be the year of the dragon okay and the
it's believed that people who are born
the year of the rabbit are gentle quiet
and very responsive and it's also a very
good communicator because uh if a person
who are born you have the tiger married
a person who are born in the of the
Dragon supposedly they might have heart
shifts because you both are very
powerful okay animals they're going to
fight for power sure the rabbit in
between as an animal can help mediate
the relationships I love this let's talk
what are some of the celebrations you
guys have planned at the Grand Canal
show we're celebrating all month long we
have two really wonderful selfie spots
that people can come down and visit
um traditional Chinese lanterns and then
we also have our golden dragon and then
we're also kicking off the city-wide
activations with the 12th annual Chinese
near in the desert yeah touch on that so
what is that what what's happening with
that so throughout the city there's a
bunch of different activations we're
kicking it off
um so we'll have a big celebration
including traditional um performances
Chinese performances in St Mark's Square
and is there any entertainment happening
at the Grand Canal shops yes so all
weekend long so we'll have different
cultural performances and come on by and
visit us it is a celebration and now
they're the full backstory I'm gonna
wear some Reds I'm going to be down
there making lots of noise this is it is
a celebration is there a website to get
information or buy tickets or what's the
website for more information it's all
complimentary visit us at Grand
canalthtracks.com I love it thank you
guys so much and happy New Year